the kids are back in school in addition
to the pencils the folders the backpacks
that they need there's some other things
you may want to pick up lifestyle expert
samantha vickers is here to tell us more
about the four things you need to put on
your list hi sam hello it's so good to
be here good to have you back and i
always can depend on you to introduce me
to new and fabulous things that i need
to get so let's get to it what do you
get okay so it's a time of excitement
but there can be some stress especially
for teachers and so i wanted to start
with something for them this is actually
canva for education so canva that we all
know and love we use all the time yes
they have education things so they have
posters and these are free so free
templates for posters lesson plans
things that they can print off for
flyers for school and they are doing
something amazing on august 26th they
are going to offer vouchers to teachers
and students so you can print all of the
things that you have gotten together for
your classroom so you need to go to the
the um link on the screen right now it's
canva dot me back back to school okay
and get all the details for that and get
your vouchers to print all of your
goodies from canva that is amazing i
didn't realize that they had like free
templates and all that i use canva all
the time but teachers there you go and
they they deserve it too what they do
they do so amazing to support them and
you and anytime they can go to canva.com
backslash education and get all those
free resources oh you gotta check that
out brilliant okay let's talk about
where it's time to pack lunch for the
kids you want to give them something
they'll eat but yeah they want something
that's not that great for them yes
absolutely so this is good olds and it's
actually really good really um and it's
good for you so there is this is a
reinvention of macaroni and cheese so
this has got protein in it it's got
fiber it's got 21 nutrients from real
plants and so much more and there's so
many fun flavors so i have to read these
so i get them right because they're so
cute chatty mac mover and shaker shell a
good twist my parm and vegan is
believing oh my gosh it's so adorable
and they say they taste better they
taste just the same or if not better
than the regular mac and cheese
absolutely i tested on my kids and they
were like this is cheesier than normal
what's going on because i didn't tell
them and so it's good stuff so you can
find this target yeah it's good target
and whole foods nationwide or you can go
to goodwills.com okay that is a perfect
thing for the lunches let's talk about
for yourself or maybe for your kids to
help them maybe wind down at the end of
the day what is this exactly okay so
this is apollo neuro i wanted to you
know i said we can have some anxiety
some stress especially after all of the
things our kids have gone through and
teachers have gone through in the last
couple of years this is a wearable
device so on your wrist or on your ankle
and what it does is it has gentle
vibrations that it puts into your body
that helps to regulate your nervous
system so if you can have a regulated
nervous system you're going to get
better focus less stress less anxiety
better sleep um clarity it just it's
amazing i feel it yeah and i do want i
it's just such a gentle vibration yeah i
could see it just helping you calm down
i already actually feel myself kind of
calming down yes you do you do i should
be wearing one right now wow this is
amazing i love this yeah and it's good
for like i said adults to kids so it's
it's so gentle that kids can have it too
so if you have a child that has anxiety
get them in a polyneuro oh where did
they get this apollonium.com brilliant
i'm going to keep this on while we do
this last one this is one of my this is
like
so cute
so i had to include a local brand here i
love this is wildest calling wildest
calling apparel
this is from natalie she designs it
she's the owner she does everything and
it's so cute this is her shirt this is
one of her shirts
it's like nevada based and i got to show
you this shirt i don't know if we can
get a close-up on it this is the cutest
thing i've ever seen it's got some of
the it says native kid at the bottom and
it's got places that native kids go red
rock new wet and wild trampoline parks
mount charleston splash pads it is just
so adorable yeah she loves to share her
nevada pride and you know just the love
of the west and these are all small
batch teas that she hand prints too so
she always is producing something new
and fresh so wildestcalling.com for her
love it thank you so much sam you always
have the best stuff if people want to
find you where can they find well to
make it really easy i'm going to link to
everything on my instagram at sam i am
vickers and i will put on my website
samanthavickers.com there you go love it
thank you so